today more than half the world's poorest
people live in sub-saharan Africa why
why is it that most of Africa stays poor
while other parts of the world prosper
people have lots of theories clean water
is simply hard to find the present-day
problems of the African continent are
tied to its colonial history what I say
my god Wade's explanation makes the most
sense African governments simply have
too many rules once you hire someone
good luck getting rid of them for any
reason then there's taxes the tax code
is so complicated some people say it's
worth at least two or three truckloads
of paper wade started this lip-balm
company in senegal some ingredients she
needs are not made there so she imports
them but the government makes that
expensive some of them have a 70% import
tariff on them so it almost doubles the
price of factly many people then escape
the tax by paying bribes we hear about
African corruption people complain about
corruption as a corruption is a root
problem
I say no corruption is also a natural
consequence of stupid senseless idiot
laws there'd be just as much corruption
in America if we had these rules
absolutely the only way to fix
corruption is to simplify Wade's
business survive because she was
fortunate to find a helpful bureaucrat I
went to see the head of customs and we
started looking together
he didn't demand a bribe we found a
clause in one of the binders saying
actually if you're exporting at least
80% of your products and if you've been
in business for two years then you can
ask for an exemption you survive through
a loophole but that takes connections
and time exactly exactly
I imagine the leaders of these countries
mostly mean well what they see how
damaging this is why do they impose all
these rules I am not so sure that all of
them get it look at the UN the
sustainable development goals
the UN's Development Goals include
things like inclusive and equitable
education climate change and gender
equality there's no mention of rules
that kill business
have changed around our necks no one is
seeing it and then they want to come
talk to me about inequality we need
greater economic freedom simple rules
that everyone can understand yes but
that VAT Diagnostics is known by almost
no one it should be no if you just look
at the rest of the world you can see
what's worked and what hasn't weighed
just made this movie about that why is
it that a couple decades ago you know
China was at the same level as most
African countries countries like
Singapore made it countries like Hong
Kong made it even a place like Dubai
bare land of sand desert sand and all of
a sudden within 12 15 years Dubai one of
the financial centers of the world and
you're like what what happened here
they understood if we do not work hard
to make it easy for businesses to set up
and be ran no businesses is gonna come
but international aid organizations have
a different solution
they say the nations of the world need
to send more help governments already
send fifty billion dollars a year to
Africa and companies promote themselves
by donating what if I started a shoe
company and every time I sold a pair of
shoes I gave a pair way these kids will
have shoes for the rest of their life
TOMS shoes is donated 93 million pairs
of shoes do you know that we have 230 I
think 232 shoe making small businesses
each one of them hiring directly at
least 15 people in this little village
yes so when you buy your shoes in the US
and pairs of shoes are being put in a
container to be shipped over to my
village shoemaker has now to close the
doors because who can compete against
free this man still in business but it's
a struggle I'm a big dumb a big me at
the car I'm a tell you for in a setting
you set them on to please some we defer
I download the canoe you could I know it
came from a good place
I got it but can you just think further
down the road unless you think that we
really sincerely have nothing including
even shoemakers and I think that's
terrible
[Music]
yet TOMS shoes two-for-one deal is
popular one company started it did so
well with it with a buy one we're gonna
give one for free to poor people but now
you're seeing it with tampons you're
seeing it with soap you're seeing it
with everything it would be better this
way if Westerners encouraged African
governments to stop strangling their own
entrepreneurs if I have a job then guess
what my malnutrition problem goes poof
my even access to clean water goes poof
you know it just but without jobs
millions risked their lives trying to
get to richer country some of my most
entrepreneurial people who are right now
serving as fish food at the bottom of
the ocean because there is not enough
jobs and why there is not enough jobs
because the business climate sucks so
much that people like me can't do their
work of creating companies and jobs many
of those deaths would be prevented if
Africa just didn't have so many dumb
rules and that's what what inequality we
should talk about no one talks about it
an equal playing field of rules yes yes
let's create greater economic freedom in
all countries so that all people
everywhere get a chance to free
enterprise